this next story just made headlines and
when i saw it i wanted to talk to her so
bad local news anchor lena pringle
from florida became the story herself
she posted a photo of her new short
haircut
and it went viral and here to tell us
why that is so
important is lena pragel herself
hi lina thank you so much hi good
morning
good morning thank you so much for
coming on the show this story is really
important
and you were experiencing pressure in
the workplace
and you posted this photo and it went
bananas
and will you please just tell me
everything about it
yeah so uh the caption is you know a
shout out to the people who told me
i wouldn't be able to get or keep a
broadcast news job with a short
natural haircut jokes on you huh with a
few cute emojis
so um a few weeks ago um
i just haven't been in the best mental
state um
i have been depressed i've been in a rut
i've just not been completely there
and you know i my friend actually sent
me a picture of this haircut and my hair
has already been short
so you know i was like why not try
something different because when you
look good you feel good
i was really just looking for a morale
booster to get out of
such a low time um and so you know i
went to my hairdresser she hooked me up
shout out to keisha she did great here
in jacksonville
and you know i took these pictures
because i felt good
i looked good and i said you know what
let me just post this i post pictures
all the time so this isn't anything new
now the attention definitely is and it's
been retweeted over 10
000 times with a ton of positive
responses
yeah i i just can't believe it
something that was literally done as a
way to
boost my morale i'm a huge mental health
advocate so something that was
so simple in nature to me that has
gained
so much attention and encouragement and
support
i am just honestly it's still i'm in awe
i just
can't believe the outreach from people
you know i'm hearing from girls in
high school to women with phds to you
know men and
barbers and all types of people who are
just
showing their genuine love and support
for authenticity
and i just can't oh i'm so sorry no
i'm so sorry oh no well
you know one of the things that i really
love about this is the risk that you
took
this wasn't just you know empowerment
and bravery you have
high stakes at work and a dove study
found that black women are like 80
percent more likely to change their
natural hair to meet expectations in the
workplace
and dev has been leaving this charge
with the crown act and in fact
yesterday um it got uh
it's it's announced that they passed at
least in the house a bill
which is one step forward you know to
not having
hair race-based you know work
discrimination
and so i think what you did is really
important for this movement
and dove even retweeted your photo
yeah dub and the crowned ads um you know
i think it's so amazing because
in 2020 there literally has to be a law
passed
nationwide to prohibit discrimination
against
natural hair simply the way our hair
grows
out of our head there has to be a law
that's passed
just so we're able to not be
discriminated against and you know it's
crazy because
last year when the crown act passed in
california it was a huge landmark
decision but at that point there was
only a few states
that were behind it so now to see this
pass in the house and move forward
i know for me and several other
black women in this industry
particularly i'm an industry that's
built upon
looks and aesthetics you know for
we stand you know this charge has been
happening for the past 15 to 20 years
there have been women that have been
knocking down the barriers that have
been saying you know what you will
accept me i am going to take up this
space
so i think it's a beautiful moment right
now because you're seeing more
black women on air with natural hair
locks
braids literally taking up all the space
and just being who they are
wow and it's a beautiful thing because
we stand on the shoulders of the women
that have been knocking down the door so
that we're able to do this
and i thank you for everything that you
are doing and that's why we wanted to
celebrate you here today and thank you
for being here and sharing this story
and breaking this news with us
and thank you lena
[Music]
you